if it's the right person telling me not
to do something I got something here I
think jay-z said it that's like make
your first you lass everytime everything
you do you have to do it like it's the
last thing you're ever gonna do some
guys watch stuff oh I want to do a movie
like that
and I watch movie so I go okay I don't
want to do that because I saw it I'm
just trying to do the best work I can
work that I can be proud of later on
when I see this thing play in front of
an audience people go crazy at every
point in my life there's no point where
I wasn't obsessed what comedy you can't
make a woman happen it's impossible I've
never met a happy woman in my life he's
an American comedian actor and producer
after working as a stand-up comic he
came to wider prominence as a cast
member of Saturday Night Live he was
voted as the fifth greatest stand-up
comedian of all time in a poll by Comedy
Central he's Chris Rock and here's my
take on his top ten rules for success
number six is my personal favorite and
make sure to stick around all the way to
the end for some special bonuses you
people trying to tell you not to say
things all the time but you know I
practice everything it's not like I ever
get up there and think of something on
stage I think of something on TV I'm
pretty much you know trying it out yeah
and honestly sometimes if it's the right
person telling me not to do something oh
I got something here yeah you know I
mean like oh you don't like it if it
must be good there's a Mitchell you set
a high benchmark certainly with a
standard because on a high benchmark how
do you keep pushing past that line
uh I mean it's almost like every I think
jay-z said it
that's like make you first you'll ass
every time everything you do you have to
do it like it's the last thing you're
ever gonna do and you know to get
maximum effort out of it but he also
goes when you when you start something
it's almost like it has to be a calling
again you know like I will you know
we're all like preachers I was called in
to stand up I was called in to comedy
and you know I just
the next project has to be something
that just
calls me you know I mean I I'm I'm a
decent businessman you know but III just
really have to be emotionally attached
to something before I leave your early
life I also heard that you went to a
school that was out of your initial
neighborhood
it was bust I was bust to school it was
pretty um you know whatever man people
you know we're mean and they called you
[ __ ] and whatever and spit on you and
through feces and piss and whatever at
you and you know that is what it is it's
nothing I can do about it it made me
stronger
I'm not here without it you can't shake
you can't faze me with meanness because
of it so you know that would that was my
grade school experience grade school
high school junior high school and um
what inspired this story for you I just
wanted you know I'm always my interest
is always like what habit I seem em you
know some guys watch stuff I want to do
a movie like that and I watch movies I
go okay I don't want to do that because
I saw it now one can I come up with and
I haven't seen this movie yeah you know
and I really haven't seen this movie
with a black person yeah I mean so
that's me it's you know this gets me
into trouble sometimes but I'm just kind
of curious that way like okay can we see
a new movie how do you personally
navigate it is it really that easy for
you that simple
you crack a joke and keep moving I just
keep moving because here's the thing
with me I don't take the adulation that
serious because if I if I put you know
if you know this if the New York Times
says oh he's a genius and I just run
around go I'm a genius the New York
Times says I'm a genius then if they say
I'm an idiot I gotta say that too that
has to be important to me too so I find
that if I don't pay attention to any of
it that I can ignore the bad stuff yeah
that's me
a lot of people
take you no criticism bought a heart I
just I just worry about my fans that's
it that's that's the only people I'm
worried about you say worry about your
fingers you mean by that what I'm just
concerned with what my fans feel like
how they feel about the art how do you
how do you feel about the movie how do
you feel about this me as a person
the people that are into me not the
people that aren't in to be you know I
mean like I don't I don't listen to
country music so I am not qualified to
say you know the Travis Tritt album is
not good so I think only people that are
your fans could be your critics you know
I've been right you know I could say
maybe say a Prince album I don't like
but there are none but you know I mean
because I listen to Prince right so yeah
I'm fine
but you've often said the top five is a
kind of make-or-break movie because
you've written it you've directed it as
well as being in it I mean you could
have chosen the predictable path
couldn't you and just have taken your
comedy and gotten bigger and bigger and
bigger
but you haven't uh I mean I could have
done something more contrived yes I
could have done something where my
partner is killed I'm a cop and they
kill my partner and I have to get
revenge on the killers of my partner I
could have done that movie which
everybody does and it probably would
have been bigger than that by ah but it
would have been better would have been
better so yeah I don't know I'm just
trying to do the best work I can work
that I can be proud of later on work
that you know works on different levels
you know a good movie or good stand-up
is different every time you watch it I
was like what how important was it for
you to get this large ensemble of you
know your friends these very talented
comedians these new comedians as well
you know how like why was that important
for you to do it was just important to
get the best people in the parts that
was pretty much it I mean and it's hard
to make comedy with strangers so you got
to know people so you know I know Cedric
so I know that part of him I know the
gritty part is Cedric the Entertainer
that everybody else might not know go
from there sir
no no cuz I'm the man used to make okay
tit right now the man and you I know
that JB's have you know been married for
like 20 years and he's got couple
daughters and I know he can be like a
calming influence where most time you
see JB in a movie he's crazy yeah oh I
love me a big girl you move with
confidence I'm not talking bull so I'm
seeing somebody no problem come on shut
the [ __ ] up my face so you know I know
this about it's easier to work with
people you know sometimes you're happy
with it though I'm real happy here yeah
when I see this thing play in front of
an audience people go crazy
yeah what's what she is one those inside
the Actor's Studio course yeah
so what's your process once you want you
do this you want to watch it with other
audiences you don't want to see it you
study this thing what's your process
wants you once they say cut you know you
cut it up you know you got to watch what
it audience it's not drama right drama
is what ever you want it to be when you
when you make drama you're like Picasso
and it's like okay whatever when you
make comedy you're not that kind of
painter you like a painter down at the
promenade painting portraits to people
if you know you want more blue in the
eyes I'm gonna put more booyah what you
want to be taller okay you're taller
you know I'm one of those guys right
that's so when you make comedy you make
it for the people that you know you try
to have as many screenings it just many
tested you do focus groups and you read
the cards you try to try to get the
people what they want this comedy man
where did the comedy part coming because
you left high school to start the comedy
career didn't you was comedy like a way
of getting back at the bullies or where
did it come I've always liked comedy I
was always interested in comedians even
when I was in a kid in second class
seven years old
I thought Bill Cosby was unbelievable
and I thought you know I mean Richard
Pryor and Don bring all these guys
Eileen I would watch the Dean Martin
roasts and all of that stuff
Abbadon
Stello you know at every point in my
life there's no point where I wasn't
obsessed what comedy and I'm still
obsessed to this day you know so you
know I it was just a natural thing for
me to do anybody in this room that's
ever been in love or testify to this
[ __ ] and you haven't contemplated murder
you ain't been ins up and you haven't
thought about gonna you ain't been in
love if you haven't had a can of rat
poison in your hand and looked at it for
45 minutes straight you ain't been in
love if you haven't bought a shovel and
a bag and a rub to roll a ass something
you ain't been in love
if you haven't practiced your alibi in
front of the mirror
do I feel in love and the only thing
that stopped you from killing us was an
episode of CSI
oh man named Karim I'm gonna make up
they might catch my ass that's right see
relationships are hard man but for order
for any relationship to work both people
have to be on the same page both people
have to have the same focus that's right
and we all know what that page is we all
know is that focuses in order for the
relationship to work both people that I
have the same focus and once that focus
the focus is all about her it's all
about her she's already there fellas
she white and feudin come on fellas when
you wake up in the morning you should
look yourself in the mirror and say yeah
your hopes your dreams your plans
everything you thought this life is
going to break you now let's go out
there and try to make this happen
it's all about her fellas say yes to
everything everything everything you
could afford say yes to just say yes
before she even gets it out of her mouth
honey can guess honey I wanna guess how
do you have I guess just get a stamp yes
yes yes yes yes yes yep another thing
fellows don't argue you cannot win you
cannot beat a woman and an argument as
impossible you will not win those men we
are handicapped when it comes to arguing
because we have a need to make sense
whether they gonna let a little thing
like since book of the argument cuz she
nodded at the since she's in it for
distance and irritation how long did I
talk the fullness a stops
they want you to shake this lot of them
do hitter cops come I'm serious
that's right and like I said try your
best to make her happy
try your best but here's what they
nobody tells you you can't make a woman
happen it's impossible I've never met a
happy woman in my life women always
complaining about southpaw she women
like they can play women save up the
complaining about oh he don't even know
I know I'm gonna get his ass on that
next month
they like complaining they love it no
matter what you do she'll be mad you
look a woman with a diamond and make a
[ __ ] in time she'll still could play why
you made me come so hard
this diamond is clouding why don't you
go to Tiffany's yourself cheap no matter
what you do yo woman is mad at you if
you work all the time let you go inside
you ain't never hope you always leaving
me I hate this
if you home all the time
why are you all up under me let me get
some room to breathe damn stop sweating
me I hate this if you make more money
huh
you I want to make decisions too you
ain't my daddy I'll need you to take
care of me I hate this if she makes more
money than you you broke you never have
no money then shall I want to make all
these decisions I need to be taken care
of I hate things I can't take it and the
number one reason young woman's always
mad fellas the number one reason your
woman is pissed off cuz you ain't her
first choice
fellas you ever catch your woman just
looking at you but not saying nothing
and hop on she's thinking how did I end
up with this ugly
Oh Lord this is ugly and stupid I had a
good man in a blue damn Lord killed my
man Jill please kill him while I still
look good enough to get something new
please kill this now strike a strike
them if you out there Lord strike this
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this beauty because Chris Turney a
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur you want me to profile next
leave it in the comments below and I'll
see what I can do I also love to know
what your Chris Rock's top ten rules had
the biggest impact on you and why which
one really made you think and feel is
going to change the way you do something
in your business or your life leave it
down in the comments I will join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
yeah my grandfather my dad
fathers a preacher I used to spend a lot
of time with him I would watch him write
his sermons I pretty much do what he did
he'd write the topics and then he would
riff on the topics and I kind of do
comedy like he preached is there also
like another relationship is when you're
delivering a sermon you were trying to
get it a truth you are trying to get a
true I mean I watch reverends as much as
I watch comedians i watch TD jakes every
Sunday I watched Joel Osteen every
Sunday now why cuz they're really good
performers and they're doing exactly the
same thing I'm doing they're just gone
for a different thing you said there was
a time when you thought when you were
doing something you felt like you were
bad for so long like how did what do you
mean like bad for so long and how did
you move over that I mean when you start
out when we do anything I'm sure like
you've written you've been writing for a
long time if you look at something you
wrote 10 years ago like oh my god did I
think this was decent so it's not that I
was bad it was just when I look back at
it like wow I did not even have an
inkling of what I was doing till about
eight years in my father never really
saw uh what I became you never really
saw it um I met Eddie Murphy actually
that was like kind of cool for him but
he you know my father was like Richard
Pryor man so know that even that wasn't
even there's like half a big deal no oh
that's your friend I guess he funny you
know it's like wasn't really a big deal
meeting Eddie Murphy but yeah my father
never saw any of this stuff so he passed
away my dad died in 88 of Kevin ulcer
explode so if you haven't also get it
checked out and you know it triggered a
bunch of the stuff you had high blood
pressure he had diabetes II was you just
only just he was just poor and working
since he was like 12 and as you know
didn't have a good diet and body just
gave up do you regret that he didn't get
to see you succeed
oh I mean you know I think about it
probably every day I think about it
every day
but also you know sometimes tragedy can
be the best thing what would I would I
feel the need to have the drive I do if
he was alive
alright cuz you know he was my safety
blanket and you know without the safety
blanket is like okay I got it the part
of me is just constantly trying to
create that again trying to recreate
security that's like trying to make
money and trying to you know write
movies all the time and you know I'm
like always resting on your laurels yeah
I'm not really I'm not resting for a guy
that's been doing this a long time I'm
not really resting and part of that is
just trying to recreate the security I
had as a child as a and that that's
never gonna happen but I can do it for
my kids you know I'm never I'm never
going to be secure again but my kids can